some breaking news out of college
football and that's where we turn to
uh our phone lines and our guests from
the athletic and fox sports
our buddy bruce feldman back here bruce
i just saw you tweeted something out in
the commercial break go for it you got
the floor here
yeah rich real breaking news uh
tomorrow's houston baylor game which
actually only came together
a week ago uh that has now been
postponed as i can
as i reported on twitter just like
literally like two minutes ago so
uh baylor is dealing with some covid
issues there and so that game
maybe it'll get rescheduled but really
hard news for both schools because
i mean for houston this was a
game that came together quickly because
their memphis game because of cove
issues that memphis got postponed and so
this is just the you know the latest in
a series of postponements and i think
what's
you know maybe more unique about this is
some people are looking at it going well
a lot of these postponements have
happened to group of five games
and this involves directly a big 12
team so when people look at it go maybe
it's the resources on the testing issue
or whatever
but it's it's showing that this this
issue
is affecting everybody in college
football well again because um
you know and knock on wood that we're
now 17 games and then the nfl season
bubbling up as professionals in a uh an
environment where
uh you spend as a professional just
multiple hours and then you go home to
your home as opposed to say a dorm room
or off-campus housing where all sorts of
craziness could go down that
uh is something that a professional
football player is avoiding or being
told to avoid or would lose money if
they didn't avoid
that are are we learning here that this
whole stuff about hey big 10's back
and that we're waiting for sec football
that this is all
just in par for the course or are we
going to
like what do you make of of of this news
and
and how we can apply it to everything
that's going on bruce
it's definitely more complicated with
college football rich i mean you have
big rosters of basically 100 guys plus
you know 40 50 staff members you're on
college campuses and as
much as a lot of athletic directors and
coaches have probably urged
their players to hey try let's try to
have as much of a bubble-like
situation as we can meaning take your
classes online don't go on campus
if you really don't have to they're
still going to be around
college students in college towns and
that gives them
more risk of exposure and quote bringing
it into their facility
so that it's complicated it really is
and right now where they are with the
testing
daily testing is coming but it's not
there yet i mean even the conferences in
the big
10 and the pac-12 which are lining up
deals in the pac-12 already has it they
don't have those
those tests yet so i think that's made
it more complicated right
so let's get to it uh one by one uh the
big ten
and uh where's the schedule
you know i i was i started by basically
saying
today it was a pr disaster or the last
time you put a schedule out you
cancelled
maybe to make everyone forget about the
pr disaster now that it's back
why aren't we talking about a schedule
when are we going to get that and and
and and how did it all come together
bruce what happened well yeah let's
start with that part first rich so
one of the issues i heard that that they
felt like they were able to address
with their meetings last week through
their medical experts was
that they had a better handle on the
myocarditis
cardiac issue and in terms of
what was one of the one of the
challenges they had
back in august was some of the schools
did not
have the protocols in place may not have
had the resources in place
to address it properly and now they feel
like they have a better handle on that
they felt like there were now daily
testing options more available and that
was something
that i think they now feel more
comfortable when they get it in place
in terms of that timeline but but you're
right in terms of
just the explanation of it on the front
end i mean
it was not well handled by the big ten
at all so they're going to move forward
we'll see when they can
put together a schedule that we know a
timeline at least of hey they're going
to be
trying to play i guess basically a month
from now
um and right through into
into mid late december so they can
hopefully
have teams in cfp consideration
but there's just a lot of tbd's going on
i mean i talked to bob bolesby who's the
big 12 commissioner and
as it relates to that cfp issue and how
they
uh you know who's eligible for playoff
consideration
and even if they don't have many games
in they might have three games in
if you're talking about the big ten when
the first rankings come out well at
least
in theory they would have maybe eight
games in when the
when the final rankings actually matter
before
selection but again as bowls we point
you know there's no guarantees that they
won't have breaks in their schedule just
like we're seeing
in other leagues and again i think
that's the
that's the challenge here i think people
look at it go okay well now they're back
saying they're going to play
well let's keep our fingers crossed so
they can and get to that point
if ohio state goes 9-0 pardon me the
ohio state goes 9-0 including winning a
big ten championship game
uh good luck to bulesby and everybody
else um
trying to keep ohio state out cause he
hadn't played enough good luck to that i
mean
because we everything i'm hearing is
that
there was a scarlet and gray hand
pushing
everything maybe a little bit of uh
cornhusker red
but it really was a scarlet and gray
hand um
that was pushing a lot to get the big
ten to meet again
and review a science the science that
i can't imagine it changed literally in
three four weeks and then
find uh rapid testing that i'm sure the
big ten
knew existed when they decided to stop
playing it's not as if
nobody in the testing business knocked
on the big ten door and say
what about us i mean this whole thing
just
i you know i i honestly don't get it i
guess i'll be happy
if it happens and everybody's safe but
um
good luck again to ohio state being kept
out if the big ten
uh has uh uh
ohio state winning their championship
bruce
yeah no i i think that if they have
enough games in look
the difference between whit going 9-0
versus potentially 10-0
with a non-conference game that's a you
know a mediocre opponent
uh i don't think that's gonna that would
hurt ohio state or hurt penn state or
whoever that team
if if there's a team from the big ten
that comes out of there like that
i mean there's not a big difference in
that one game assuming
can that they can you know not have
postponements to derail the schedule
right and so i do think it's noteworthy
that the big ten
what they have now has a stricter
criteria
to control some of these things so
that's not
you know that may impact it in a
different way
but right now i think we're just trying
to figure out where does this all
where's this all going to go bruce
feldman the athletic and fox sports here
on the rich eisen show and then there's
the pac-12
where the governor of our state out here
in california gavin newsom is just like
don't look at me um if the pac-12 is
saying that
the you know health rules are preventing
a couple of states and certainly the
state of california from
restarting so if gavin newsom saying no
is it is it los angeles
that's basically telling us usc that
they can't go i mean
what is going on with the pac-12 right
now is it i guess
the big question yeah it was government
ordinances that were really
you know putting up the roadblock at
that point but you know we did a big
story on the athletic
that ran that went up yesterday
afternoon
there are a lot of coaches in the league
who feel strongly that the
that the pac-12 is not going to be ready
to play
uh as fast as some people in the pac-12
leadership
want them out there and it has more to
do with
look we have not there's a difference
between being in cardio shape and
actually being in football shape and if
we're going to pre-child
safety and the wellness of our student
athletes is our number one priority
and our guys are not ready to play
football where they're going to be risks
all sorts of soft tissue injuries and
all and other kinds of things like that
then we're doing a disservice to them
and i would encourage people to look at
that story
at the athletic because some of the
quotes from some of those coaches
are eye-popping about basically the
pac-12
having its head up the the big tens you
know what
i mean in the language is colorful and
there's a lot of people who are
there are coaches in the conference who
are really frustrated
with how with how all this has been
handled
and the perception that it's just being
shoved down
their throats right now probably faster
than it's probably
probably in the player's best interest
[Laughter]
man i guess again covert in in every
walk of life just finds the weakness
and places immense pressure upon it and
then
uh reveals um a lot of the fault lines
there's no
doubt about it and you know the pac-12
may be feeling pressure to have to go
because if they don't go and everyone
else goes
i mean the pac-12 could be irreparably
harmed uh
for years to come in terms of kids like
not going there or anything like that
um whether that's fair or not uh that
that does appear to be the pressure
that's upon
that conference bruce would you not
agree
yeah i i i feel like that's probably a
little overblown
to think it you know we everything
happened so fast in this day and age and
people move on the difference between a
big
like let's say if the pac-12 starts on
november 7th
which is the the coaches i talked to
yesterday thought
except for one one thought it was too
soon for this but thought november 15th
was something they could
was workable uh they could get to be
ready at that point
the idea that they could play in october
they the coaches i talked to
thought it was not realistic and it
wasn't smart
now the difference between one and you
know them playing a a
six game schedule versus a five game
schedule
are if recruits are going to hold that
one game or that perception
against them where they're not going to
choose those schools they're going to go
to other conferences
i don't i don't know that doesn't kind
of pass the smell
test to me i mean that's just an opinion
but
i don't know if i would go that far but
i think at this point
you know it feels a lot like again for
my reporting that it's just like
the pac-12 a lot of times just can't get
out of its own way when it comes to some
of this stuff and it just kind of
the leadership of the conference seems
to shoot itself in the foot
almost at every critical turn and the
sec is going right i mean that's
obviously the one that everyone is
keeping an eye on to see what their
plans are and they're they're going
right they're going yeah they're going
to start on the 26th which is a week
from tomorrow now look keep in mind
missouri has already announced that they
have 12 players out
for their opener against alabama and
that number could certainly go up
because
they're going to have you know a few
more tests between now and then
so you know like one of the things i
think people should be cautious of
is like going yeah this this conference
is the loser in this and this conference
is a big winner
because the fcc hasn't played a game yet
right i mean
the big 12 hasn't played a conference
game yet and they've already had
smu i'm sorry they've already had tcu
and baylor lose games now
uh because of what's gone on so
um it's gonna be this is
you know gonna be a long bumpy ride i'm
afraid yeah it's such a shame
last one for you uh my friend prime has
gone dark on my text exchange
um is dion the next coach at jackson
state
what are you hearing it sounds like that
there was some misdirection coming out
of uh
coming out of the school i guess
yesterday they told some reporters some
things that were probably
not accurate um it would definitely make
things more interesting think about this
in this in division one football in the
state of mississippi you would have
mike leach lane kiffin and now dion
sanders
uh buckle up i i
i agree uh i mean just in terms of um
but i'll tell you what anybody that uh
and i mean this and it's not just
because i'm
i consider him a a great friend anybody
that thinks that this would be a lark
for dion is mistaken
uh i i think he would bring uh an
all-star
cast with him um for coaches and i think
he would be a dynamite coach
i think he's ready for it i i i oh you
overlook him at your peril essentially
is what i'm saying
fair enough i mean i think what this is
because it's not a school with a lot of
resources at this point
it's obviously out of school with really
good history and some they produce some
some legends as obviously you guys know
but
uh i would imagine this would if it goes
well
if it goes well then if florida state
were to ever come or were to come open
down the road and it's way too early to
make any judgments on mike norvell after
one game
right but i think that would give him
uh a much better shot at getting a
bigger job
if he really wants to do that and also i
mean look
you know this isn't and i'm not saying
this is means he can't coach her
at all but like we've seen in the nba
you can be a really good player
and you can make a rel seamless
transition into coaching
you'll almost never see a college
a football star just jump in and get a
head coaching job
in college because there's just so much
that goes into it
so there's usually a step along the way
that you probably have to take to kind
of get up to that
that point and maybe this is that step
for him bruce thanks for the call be
safe where are you are you anywhere this
weekend where are you going
i am in studio uh and so it'll be
interesting to watch some of the games
but you know like as i said it's
uh going to be a fascinating ride bruce
thanks for the call you take care of
yourself
my pleasure well chats that's bruce
feldman fox sports the athletic
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here